bonsoir et bienvenue nous sommes en
direct c'est ça vous regarde et je suis
ravi de vous retrouver au sommaire ce
soir emmanuel macron à la rescousse de
son camp le chef de l'état s'est exprimé
depuis le tarmac de l'aéroport d'orly
avant de s'envoler pour la roumanie
aucune voix ne doit manquer à la
république at il dit dans une allocution
pour le moins surprenante on va y
revenir quand la macro ni est sous
pression à quatre jours du second tour
c'est notre grand débat avec nos invités
dans un instant sur ce plateau lui rêve
d'un sauveur notre grand témoin
n'épargne ni emmanuel macron ni
l'opposition ni même les français dans
son dernier livre mais en l'intitulant
en attendant de gaulle il sait bien que
comme le godot de samuel beckett
celui-ci ne viendra jamais fog franz
olivier giesbert est avec nous ce soir
enfin nous trouverons aux affranchis
pour leur parti pris le carnet de
campagne quotidien signé elsa monde un
gars va le regard de gens les niveaux
d'eau macron l'enfant gâté de la
politique pour la première fois malmené
et fanny guinochet pour l'économie va
t-on vers un report des baisses d'impôts
pour les entreprises voilà pour le menu
[Musique]
et bienvenue à vous chers
téléspectateurs merci d'être au
rendez-vous bonsoir franz olivier
giesbert c'est un plaisir de vous avoir
sur ce plateau nador urd est d'ailleurs
vous invitez d'exode de passage à paris
vous l'amoureux de de marseille on va
parler tout à l'heure de votre dernier
livre en attendant de gaulle chez albin
michel vous me corrigerez parce que
apparemment vous y croyez encore au
sauveur il pourrait revenir 1 devant la
wii mais tout mais j'y crois bien sûr
non mais c'est pas juste je suis pas du
tout d'accord avec d'autres lancements
l'énergie propre
et vote de go et le 2 go c'est
évidemment c'est alors en attendant de
gauche c'était de gaulle abstrait parce
que c'est quelqu'un qu'on ne connaît pas
ici l'homme d'état le grand homme d'état
il se révèle toujours au pied du pouvoir
à part de gaulle parce qu'on savait que
c'est un personnage historique de -38
cette équipe a vraiment rien du tout en
tout cas précités kaka mais vous avez
regardé schröder je crois
oui mais la remontée complètement la
main une passe et c'était c'est alors la
rondelle et emploiera cadore vin blanc
qui était enfin personne n'aurait misé
un kopeck sur lui bon ben il a dit en
pleurant il a remis l'allemagne france
tout à l'heure ce sera dans la deuxième
partie en tout cas tous se compare à lui
et tous ne lui arrive pas à la cheville
je faisais bien lieu ce côté là va
commencer quand même par l'actualité
c'est évidemment la campagne des
législatives
et cette drôle de prise de parole
présidentielle
dimanche aucune voix ne doit manquer à
la république dimanche je compte sur
vous pour doter notre pays d'une
majorité solide
afin d'affronter tous les défis de
l'époque
et de bâtir l'espoir
voilà diaboliser l'adversaire à quatre
jours du second tour au risque peut-être
de paraître un peu fébrile on vous
posera la question ce soir mode brégeon
bonsoir et merci d'être avec nous est
porte parole de la république en marche
et vous êtes candidate dans la 13e
circonscription des hauts-de-seine
qualifié pour le second tour bonsoir
rafael remis le soir ravi de vous
accueillir vous êtes porte parole
d'europe écologie les verts ile de
france et soutien de la nuque puisqu'on
dit la nuque c'est le dictionnaire de
l'académie française qui le dit grâce à
notre confrère jason wiels que je salue
ce soir coalition de gauche autour de
jean luc mélenchon philippe ballard doit
être avec nous depuis un bovin est ce
qu'ils la peau soir monsieur vous êtes
candidat rassemblement national dans la
seconde circonscription de l'oise vous
êtes arrivé largement en tête et puis le
politologue benjamin morel va nous
rejoindre dans un tout petit instant le
temps de planter le décor parce qu'il ya
un décor ce soir stéphane services
moyennant problème alors là alors il y a
un président une allocution et à un
avion en font si j'ai bien compris
stéphane blakowski tout de suite
[Musique]
alors ce soir si j'ai bien compris
stéphane si j'ai bien compris on pourra
plus reproché au président de ne pas
faire votre campagne de ne pas
s'investir dans la campagne oui et bien
que l'on croyait qu en s'absentant cette
semaine en partant roumanie puis en
moldavie dire aux impôts le coût de
jupiter je prends de la hauteur je met
de la distance je surplombe la compacte
pas du tout avant de monter dans l'avion
il a profite donc de ce belge qui sont
liées à la guerre en ukraine on a bien
compris pour dramatiser ce second tour
des élections législatives en écoute
nous avons besoin d'une majorité solide
pour assurer l'ordre à l'extérieur comme
à l'intérieur de nos frontières
rien ne serait pire que d'ajouter un
désordre français au désordre mondial
voilà sa stratégie c'est de faire peur
aux français alors peut-être stratégie à
mon ami le tient en trois mots 1 c'est
maintenant il faut y aller à fond à fond
et surtout à fond là c'est je pense que
c'est le mot d'ordre en ce moment c'est
un peu la glisse creek si vous voulez
tout aucune guerre de position qui n'a
pas mené puisqu'il n'a pas vraiment fait
campagne il s est tapé très fort un
grand coup en espagne en espérant
emporté la victoire mais vous avez
raison ce goût de la peur la victorine
macron c'est plutôt des csp + plutôt des
retraités or les bourgeois et les vieux
qu'est ce qui leur fait peur le désordre
ça je veux bien passé pour vous en
parler le désordre vraiment à notre âge
on évolue sa catégorie la mancha demeure
un peu à bout meurt quand même assez
mais regardez ce qu'a dit edouard
philippe regardez c'est exactement sur
ce registre qui n'entrent en train de
jouer en disant à quel point c'est
important d'avoir une majorité absolue
pour le camp présidentiel en une seule
phrase il a mis les mots danger il a mis
quoi encore comme mot instabilité folie
et des ordres donc vous voyez que c'est
vraiment tiré le signal d'alarmé est la
cible prioritaire c'est jean luc
mélenchon l'imaginer dans la mesure où
il ya la plupart des duels opposent
ensemble à nu ps oui indirectement mais
en fait la stratégie aux peaux de rennes
comme un oui à quelques-uns ya peut-être
même deux trois et les
délais mais la grande majorité en tous
cas les des duels se font sur
avec le nu parce qu'elle semble
simplement plus tôt que possible et
précisant mélenchon dans le camp
présidentiel on préfère au contraire m
mélenchon et le pen dans le même sac ce
qui bien sûr fait grimper aux rideaux
les gens de la nuit passe sauf que oui
elle est donc savourer riz serait un
petit peu le poil minimum en tout cas de
gabriel at elle a quand même quelques
arguments pour faire ce parallèle moi ce
que je veux dire ce matin c'est que l'on
porte un projet qui est profondément
républicain là où la nuit ps le
rassemblement national à bien des égards
s'éloigne de la république comporte un
projet qui est profondément européen
là où la nuit baisse le rassemblement
national veulent in fine et sortir de
l'union européenne comporte un projet de
libération de notre économie tournée
vers l'emploi la rémunération au travail
là vous avez en face des projets qui
sont des projets de ruine économique du
pays va toujours pas quand même un peu
énervant mais oui oui la mauvaise foi
c'est toujours énervant alors ça veut
dire quelle est leur prépa aux rideaux
emmanuel macron ne respecte pas le
fameux front républicain puis s'il ya un
point sur lequel macro et mélenchon sont
d'accord c'est pour dire pas une seule
voix ne doit aller au rassemblement
national c'est ce qu'avait dit jean luc
mélenchon le soir de sa défaite à la
présidentielle
c'est aussi ce que dit elisabeth board
avec une quand même une petite précision
anna de doom au bas du contrat c'est ce
n'est pas parce que vous ne devez pas
voter pour le pen que vous devez voter
pour mélenchon en écoute notre position
c'est aucune voix pour le front national
ensuite quand on a des candidats nuque
très clairement si on a affaire à un
candidat qui ne respectent pas les
valeurs républicaines qui insulte nos
policiers qui demande de ne plus
soutenir l'ukraine qui veut sortir de
l'europe nous n'appelons pas à voter
pour lui voilà donc elisabeth bornes qui
montent au front l'avait pas beaucoup
entendu un jusqu'à présent en même temps
c'est pas trop son sens son profil et
isabelle borne n'est pas quelqu'un qui a
un charisme monstrueux qui monte sur
scène comme jean luc mélenchon et qui
est capable d'enflammer les foules
avec des grands discours en dépit de la
pour faire un plan sur un an montant une
politique nous faire l'autre jour il
s'est quand même un petit peu lâché en
traitant jeu luc mélenchon ne manquerai
l'a pas fait publiquement l a fait dans
une réunion à sa fuite est ce qu'il
avait indigné c'est que jean luc
mélenchon accusé le gouvernement de
vouloir augmenter la tva et donc les
impôts donc la bête bande est peut-être
un peu timide ce n'est évidemment pas le
cas de gabriel attal qui est revenu sur
ce point on veut pas augmenter les
impôts on veut même continuer à les
baisser on a un programme de baisses
d'impôts en face vous avez la france
insoumise la nuque ps qui ont un
programme de 330 milliards de dépenses
supplémentaires par an c'est quasiment
un milliard de plus par jour c'est eux
qui augmenteront les impôts d'ailleurs
ils le disent dans leur programme et
mélenchon alain de machines ce cadre il
est né plupart paolin parce qu'ils en
ont assez mal à monter
qu'est-ce qui répond à tous à jean luc
mélenchon vous savez que l'année passée
occupait plus de 50% du temps d'antenne
pendant parfois jusqu'à 70 % cascio de 1
10% on ouvre la télé où on entend on
écoute la radio c'est
vraiment espèces le ps de perdre
ça va très loin
ces journalistes ont tellement enfiévré
et militants il faut bien dire qu'ils
nous expliquent toutes et tous que c'est
à l'énorme succès pour
la gauche alors que la gauche a perdu
des voix parlant de braga façon de
regarder on
va laisser
2 on a dix bien servi par les médias
la parole à jean luc mélenchon mais sans
non plus lui et c'est trop longtemps
donc il axera son blog où il a fait donc
cette petite blague que vous apprécierez
france j'imagine le bateau coule
maquereau en avions bateaux avions
il ya un long texte 1 derrière la vérité
c'est de savoir que mon second non mais
ils plaisantent en ce moment une maison
qui était donc certes il est de lesparre
fictivement de ne pas empêcher la
majorité absolue d'un réveil macron le
truc c'est à voir qui aura le sourire le
soir du second tour ça sera pas
forcément mélenchon alors on verra jean
luc mélenchon meeting ce soir à toulouse
et on va vous faire à écouter dès qu'on
aura une réaction justement sur cette
prise de parole présidentielle qui est
un peu surprenante quand même mode
région ce discours il est très politique
mais ni abstention ni confusion mais
clarification dimanche je compte sur
vous pour avoir une majorité solide il a
même dit majorité absolue au nom de
l'intérêt supérieur de la nation je cite
les mots du président ya panique à bord
c'est vraiment son rôle de faire comme
ça à ce point impliqués dans cette
campagne législative que c'est
parfaitement son rôle parce que l'enjeu
est énorme les français n'ont pas le
choix entre deux nuances politiques
différentes dimanche prochain ces deux
destins qui sont fondamentalement
différents pour la france donc a dit le
président de la république il a
d'ailleurs dit une chose très importante
qui résonne d'autant plus dans le
contexte de ce discours qui est que dans
un contexte mondial qui est extrêmement
troublée crise sanitaire sans précédent
la guerre en ukraine on a besoin de
stabilité il dit ensuite des programmes
fondamentalement différent sur l'europe
nous on croit que la france ne peut pas
être grande si l'europe n'est pas forte
jean luc mélenchon prône la dsit l'aide
désobéissance européenne sur la sécurité
jean luc mélenchon insulte la police au
sens large nous on veut la renforcer
encore la
dernière que les oui mais pas trop
dernière on vous avait autant besoin de
paix de parole je vais dire quelque
chose d'important il dit bien sûr j'ai
entendu le message qui est envoyé aux
premiers secours bien sûr on entend les
craintes on entend les peurs des
électeurs qui ont voté pour jean luc
mélenchon font voter pour marine le pen
qui ont voté pour toute autre partie
mail à l'immobilisme dans lequel nous
mettrait une majorité nuxe notamment as
nationale ne peut pas être la solution
aux attentes au mois deux régions jour
le résumé c'est extrêmement important le
résumé c'est vous le chaos pour le
résumé c'est un programme pro européen
un programme qui veut soutenir les
forces de l'ordre un programme qui est
crédible sur le plan économique pour
apporter des réponses au pouvoir d'achat
est en face effectivement un programme
de désobéissance européenne avec un
leader qui insultent de la police d
impôt supplémentaire des charges
supplémentaires du travail en moins on
distribue des richesses des richesses
qu'on produit par faudra qu'elle nous
exportons alors on sent que c'est la fin
de la campagne ça y est les couteaux
sont tirés c'est sûr raphaël rémy le
quand on regarde le texte de jean luc
mélenchon lui aussi il va fort sur cette
même allocution présidentielle avec ses
vrais bons un avion en fond c'est un peu
étrange quand même 2 juste avant de
décoller pour la roumanie de parler à ce
point politique mélenchon qui dit sketch
à la trump pour mettre en garde contre
l'ennemi de l'intérieur vous reprendriez
ces mots là oui parce qu'en fait ce qui
me dérange dans cette allocution être le
fait de pas par rapport à la plate forme
politique de 30 mai par rapport à son
utilisation notamment des grosses
ficelles de communication et des gros
moyens qu'on peut avoir quand on est
président de la république le fait de
faire la seule grande intervention de sa
campagne législative de la part d'
emmanuel macron avec l'avion
présidentiel derrière c'est franchement
très sûr jouer et en plus alors que
c'est censé être un discours sur la
république c'est en tout cas ce qu'il a
essayé de nous vendre c'est pour le coup
sortir un petit peu de son rôle
institutionnel d'autant plus que l'un de
ses arguments c'est de dire il pas une
voix ne doit manquer à la république
mais alors vous êtes chef de l'état et
que vous êtes notamment responsable de
l'ordre public du bon déroulé des
élections vous ne pouvez pas ainsi posé
l'anathème sur tout donc vous vous lavez
préfet comme une forme de désignation de
l'anip en dehors du champ bien sûr de la
république emblématique tout ce qui est
dit sur le désordre que créerait en
réalité une cohabitation mais on peut
pas avoir un président de la république
qui a peur de la démocratie qui a peur
même des institutions de la vème
république alors si demain il se
découvre partisans de la sixième
république j'en serai la première ravie
mais il faut les sélections se dérouler
en effet avec la bataille des idées on
est là j'ai trouvé que c'était un hors
champ pour le jeu
je voudrais quand même entendre tous les
politiques et ensuite je vais voir les
experts les observateurs les fins
analystes que vous êtes bon soir
benjamin morel soir à vous accueillir
vous êtes
constitutionnaliste professeur de droit
public à l'université panthéon assas
mais d'abord philippe ballard vous qui
êtes à beauvais vous n'avez pas pu rater
au moins quelques extraits du discours
des manuels matheron sur le tarmac
d'orly aucune voix ne doit manquer à la
république ça veut dire que le chef de
l'état vous place en dehors du champ
républicain avec les insoumis c'est
comme ça que vous l'avez compris
déjà ça sent un petit peu la panique à
bord ça sent l'improvisation un peu
comme dimanche soir pour les consignes
de vote même si à l'arrivée on a très
bien compris que c'était la même
histoire qu'à la présidentielle en
souvient de jean luc mélenchon pas une
voix pour marine le pen une loi pour
marine le pen donc par effet ricochet
des voix pour emmanuel macron et le
dimanche soir et depuis on assiste à ce
jeu de deux tubes en quelque sorte
ensuite pour les propos du chef de
l'état bah je sais pas qu'est ce que ça
veut dire cinq ans de stabilité ces cinq
ans de casse sociale 52 seigner fiscale
50 d'une insécurité qui ne fait que
grandir cinq ans d'une immigration
incontrôlée 50 plus pour un hôpital
public complètement à la dérive donc
voilà non évidemment ne seriez pas quand
même que ce discours présidentiel soit
soient très forts en termes de
mobilisation d'un électorat concept plus
mobilisés déjà ou législative que le
vôtre
non mais on sait alors là par contre il
va falloir regarder de plus près ce qui
s'est passé dimanche dernier parce que
effectivement
habituellement quand il ya des élections
les lots départemental on l'a vu aux
régionales on l'avait vu aux municipales
c'est notre électorat qui s'abstient le
plus électorat des classes moyennes des
classes populaires les gens ceux qui
souffrent pourtant plus de la politique
d' emmanuel macron cette fois ci ça n'a
pas été le cas on faisait 13 %
législatives de 2010 est nous sommes à
19% on gagne un million trois cent mille
voix et vous rappeliez ma candidature
dans dans l'oise ont fait exactement le
même score que marine le pen dont kylie
vraie dynamique et je vois ailleurs on a
perdu la liaison avec philippe ballard
on va essayer delà de leur prouver
franz-olivier giesbert quand même c'est
particulier cette intervention non vous
en aviez vu des comme ça le chiot nombre
attendez on découvre la lune enfin j'ai
beaucoup d'estimé pour vous mais
franchement moi j'ai des heures de vol
jusqu'à intervenez dans les campagnes
électorales
monsieur morel attendait mitterrand dit
il personne se gêner enfin c'est normal
c'est ça la politique ce que je
sais aussi que j'ai exactement le
contraire que je pencherais emmanuel
macron c'est exactement contraire il est
passé intervenu il a semblé se
désintéresser il n'y a pas eu de
campagne il a mis à matignon quelqu'un
qui n'était qu'un câble capable de faire
une campagne électorale peut-être
qu'elle peut être un bon chef de
gouvernement c'est un pas avoir montre
en tout cas comme chef de campagne chef
de la majorité parlementaire c'est
évidemment pas madame bornes qui peut
faire le boulot donc finalement il y
avait il n'y a pas eu de discours donc
enfin il parle et au monde dit ta gueule
enfin c'est grotesque
je reporte je reprends le langage de 2,2
de monsieur mélenchon s'y
attendait et l'histoire de trompes après
les valeurs ça c'est
interdit s'il ya quelqu'un qui ressemble
à trump dans cette histoire je termine
je vous laisse répondre suite101
mélenchon qui explique que we die les
élections c'est tout juste une excuse
pas qu'il a gagné et de re avec la
complicité des médias il explique qu'il
a gagné cette élection alors qu'à aucune
chance qu'ils la gagnent puisqu'il est à
20 5% et si il ya un parti qui a gagné
des électeurs dans cette affaire c'est
qu'on vient de me dire monsieur ballard
se rassemblent en acier avec à gagner un
minima la victoire
mais on a du temps pour ça vous allez
pouvoir répondre point par point y
compris sur le parallèle avec donald
trump et on va écouter jean luc
mélenchon depuis toulouse philippe
ballard qu'est ce que vous répondez
finalement à ces attaques
présidentielles vous qui quand même
malgré tout dans ce second tour n'avait
pas autant de réserves de voir que le
camp macron
non mais je pense qu'on a une vraie
dynamique parce qu'il ya deux façon de
raisonner soit vous raisonnez
effectivement en alignant les chiffres
d'une façon de faire et se fait
régulièrement mais là quand on est sur
le terrain moi je vous franchement je
suis étonné de la réaction des gens que
je rencontre quotidiennement et je
rencontre plusieurs dizaines il ya ceux
qui sont allés voter dimanche et qui
vont continuer de voter dimanche et dans
la même direction et il ya ceux qui
disent on n'est pas allés voter dimanche
on a fait une erreur on ne veut plus de
maquereaux on ne veut plus de 50 plus
dessus je vous disais il ya quelques
instants de cette caste sociale la
retraite à 65 67 ans edouard philippe
était justement à gober aujourd'hui et
nous parlait de la retraite à 67 ans
éventuel donc ça les gens n'en veulent
pas et puis ils veulent pas non plus de
ce n'est venue ni psa va pourtant alors
que l'agrégation de tous des scores de
mélenchon de l'hidalgo jadot roussel
c'est plus de 30% qui vole les femmes
ont burqini et les policiers désormais
on va voilà qui est un discours de
campagne bien rodée en quelques mois
avant de vous laisser repartir mètres
vers votre campagne filet ballard les
objectifs de marine le pen et du
rassemblement national en terme de
députés sont-ils revu à la hausse après
ce premier tour
je pense que oui encore une fois on a
une vraie dynamique marine le pen
rappelait que dans 90 circonscription
avait fait plus de 55% des voix pourquoi
pas envoyer une centaine de députés
rassemblement national au moins 60 pour
pouvoir c'est-à-dire le constitutionnel
conseil constitutionnel pardon et ça
sera évidemment beaucoup plus de quinze
députés permis de former un groupe à
l'assemblée m et rssi avoue philippe
ballard on voit dans les stratégies le
manque d'ambition au départ et puis
voilà le rassemblement national qui
augmente je vous donne la parole
benjamin morel mais je vous propose de
commenter tout de suite la première
réaction de jean-luc mélenchon des
pitchoun's son bateau coule on a
comprend l'avion
et
certains disent ils s'enfuient c'est pas
vrai moi je crois pas en réalité ils
nous méprisent parce que il avait prévu
de longue date un voyage pareil ça
s'organise pas depuis dimanche c'est pas
dimanche soir qui s'est dit oh la la il
faut que je réponde à mélenchon le mans
mais c'était prévu avant donc avant il
s'était dit l'élection législative c'est
juste une formalité administrative
donc je vais aller ailleurs me faire
remarquer et notamment sur la ligne de
front avec la russie ce qui moi me
paraît un prudent pour le chef et le
président de la république française
benjamin morel déjà jean luc mélenchon
avant de réagir avait dit il ne faut pas
partir sur le président dans cet
entre-deux-tours
expliquant que la situation française
était trop g pour pouvoir voilà absente
et si longtemps qu'est ce qui se joue là
dans cette dernière ligne droite parce
qu'ils se disent ce qui se joue dans sa
dernière ligne droite c'est une question
de participation et de mobilisation des
abstentionnistes tout à l'heure vous
disiez et bien il ya plus de réserves
pour emmanuel macron c'est pas si
évident que ça c'est à dire que on a
beaucoup regardé les résultats puis on a
regardé on a vu qu on ait l air faisait
10 % et que ces 10% on pouvait venir au
secours des manuels macron c'est pas si
évident d'abord parce qu'on a un
électorat et l'erc est beaucoup plus
polarisé que je dise et surtout parce
que cet électorat est très concentré
dans les fiefs de m il n'est pas
dispersé de manière homogène emmanuel
macron s'il veut l'emporter a besoin
mobiliser sa base sa base qui s'est
démobilisé on dit également que la nuque
cyclos et rennes n'ont pas de réserves
ses patios évident que ça le score du
rassemblement national qu'on a commenté
tout à l'heure et un score exceptionnel
pour une législative au rassemblement
national c'est pas la campagne en
filière millions de voix de plus
vraiment à riom
mental ces événements
en tout cas c'est le vrai étonnement et
c'est le vrai fait de cette législative
et cet électorat s'est pas mobilisée
parce que la campagne de marine le pen
était mary fickett n'a pas vraiment eu
de campagne de marine le pen si cet
électorat s'est mobilisé c'est pour
partie probablement parenti macro nisme
je vous laisse deviner du cou où vont
aller ces électeurs au second tour donc
il ya des réserves potentielles pour
vous il ya un vote sanction potentielle
des plus forts et un vers la d
abstention a été d'ailleurs lors des
législatives précédentes souvenez vous
des candidats on semble qui faisait 40
45 pour son premier tour et qui était
battu au second parce que justement vous
aviez des réserves pour les candidats
d'opposition donc pour le coup pour
emmanuel macron allait mobiliser sa base
qui s'est démobilisé en tenant le type
de discours qui vient de tenir ces
stratégies sont aujourd'hui nécessaires
alors à fel rémy le ça veut dire que
pour vous ce soir l'objectif d'une
majorité absolue est toujours sur la
table honnêtement franchement il est
vrai que quand on regarde les rapports
de force façon vraiment hors de portée
mais le principe de symétrie déjà
presque 200 députés des 100 sièges en
projection c'est beaucoup le rapport de
force dans notre système politique est
actée par l'élection et donc ça tombe
bien c'est dimanche prochain et merci
d'avoir rappelé ces deux faits majeurs
et je suis d'accord avec vous sur cette
analyse merci de l'avoir partagé c'est
l'abstention 53 % d'abstention et le
score du rassemblement national donc en
effet on a des réserves de voix énorme
53% de personnes à les mobiliser à les
inviter à s'engager à nouveau dans le
débat public et à toute la notion de
démocratie de contre-pouvoir tout ça
était perdue c'est ça même à nos
estimations ipsos en projection en
sièges il faut 289 et au maximum on vous
donne 100 90 voire 200 sièges donc ça
reste compliqué ça reste compliqué si on
a mobilisé plus de gens en fait j'ai un
vrai problème avec cette idée qu'on est
résigné vis-à-vis de notre propre
démocratie on ne peut pas se satisfaire
d'avoir la moitié des électeurs et des
électrices qui ne vont pas voter dans ma
classe d'âge il ya 70 % des moins de 35
ans qui ne sont pas allés voter ça ne va
pas et pas que pour la nuit passe
d'ailleurs ça ne va pas non plus pour la
majorité présidentielle c'est grave
d'avoir un tel désintérêt pour la
démocratie donc on va continuer de faire
campagne sans relâche jusqu'à
vendredi soir 23h59 on dimanche on sera
en train de tenir des bureaux de vote
mais moi j'invite vraiment tous les
partis politiques au-delà des petites
phrases incité massivement les gens elle
est votée on devrait mobiliser beaucoup
plus les pouvoirs publics pour rappeler
les élections leur fonctionnement leurs
intérêts et des choses toutes bêtes pour
me les valeurs chacun aidant est dans
son rôle finalement le président de la
république en appelant à mobiliser les
siens mélenchon se savoir et d'après moi
le président de la république avait un
mobiliser tout le monde aussi pour aller
voter et ce qui
arrange et il ya deux points du discours
qui m'ont dérangé c'est cette sorte
d'exclusion du champ républicain est le
deuxième que je trouve vraiment
problématique c'est dessiner en creux
une équivalence entre les désordres
mondiaux auxquels en effet il va les
faire face notamment en europe de l'est
et à proximité de l'ukraine est un
désordre qui seraient créés par une
cohabitation alors c'est simplement
notre fonctionnement démocratique bon on
va on va regarder sur le terrain ce qui
se passe dans une circonscription parce
qu'on voit quand même que certains de
vos candidats sont à la peine y compris
des ministres de poids peut être un
dernier mot là-dessus france quand même
c'est frappant de voir qu'il n'y a que
lui cette macro ni on a l'impression que
même on sait à lire pas mal de papiers
coulisses que beaucoup de son entourage
on dit faut que tu parles emmanuel
macron c'est très important c'est pas un
problème ne serait ce que pour cette
majorité que tout tourne alors c'est la
5ème république c'est autour d'un seul
homme c'est un problème de
fonctionnement c'est à dire que c'est
vrai si on compare à certains de ses
prédécesseurs et il aimait s'entourer de
personnalités fortes on peut pas dire
soit son cas alors il ya moins d'eau le
maire qui a réussi à survivre je ne sais
pas comment qui est toujours là qu'ils
auraient pu utiliser davantage parce
qu'il passe bien il ya aussi edouard
philippe avec lequel il est fâché on ne
sait pas pour quelle raison mais c'est
sûr que ça manque de personnalité forte
capable de faire campagne donc tout
repose sur lui il a disparu pendant la
campagne pendant les deux campagnes
présidentielles la compagnie chats type
donc puis je répète il a quand même mis
à matignon quelqu'un qui fait pour tous
sauf pour faire une campagne dolce tombe
et ont donc finalement avec ça a
finalement eu lieu pendant revient
toujours voilà là la solitude au centre
de gravité mac rognage je pense que
les français quand ils sont allés voter
les 10 et 24 avril dernier ils ont bien
sûr fait le choix d'un projet mais aussi
fait le choix d'un homme d'une femme
fonction d'eux pour qu'ils ont voté donc
c'est je crois tout à fait légitime de
sa part de prendre la parole tu es le
fait aujourd'hui maintenant moi je vois
les ministres qui se déploie et qui se
déploie sur le terrain qui se déploie
dans les médias j'ai reçu dans ma
circonscription de reno lemaire vous en
parliez georges puis gérald darmanin je
les vois pour une grande partie d'entre
elles et soutenir nos candidats et on
voit qu'il ya un effet et elian pèse
soirée et et voilà et offre aux
électeurs dont on fonctionne bien sûr
qu'on est une équipe mais je crois que
tout à fait normal que les français
aujourd'hui à 100 aussi une parole du
chef de l'état kessel qu'il peut alors
là et bien sûr et bien et c'est toujours
c'est à dire que s'il avait pas parlé on
ne leur est reproché d'avoir parlé bon
s'il avait trop par et on lui a dit vous
vous impliquez trouve dans la campagne
dont il ya aussi un analyse médiatique
qu en effet derrière je crois me manque
un peu d qu'il faudrait
il n'a pas participé à cette campagne
n'a pas fait assez campagne quand même
la rue pour deux ou trois déclarations
comme l'ont fait tous ses prédécesseurs
et à 577 campagne déjà pour commencer il
ya 577 candidats et contextes locaux qui
sont différents donc c'est d'abord et
j'aimerais bien le rappeler mais à nous
de faire campagne et se nourrir et au
législatif qui vous guide dans chacun
d'eux chacune circonscriptions
respectives et puis ensuite on a un
président qui a été élu les français ils
ont choisi un capitaine a fait alors
justement les investigateurs mais
maintenant il faut une majorité absolue
lyon rue vernet c'est tout l'enjeu ont
fait campagne de mesures conscription il
fait campagne pour la france et chacun
est à sa place direction l'essonne ou
une ministre et pas n'importe laquelle
amélie de montchalin ministre de la
transition écologique est en difficulté
face à rennes jérôme guedj reportage
nicolas kouadio avec antoine coutin
c'est une ministre qui joue gros en
ballottage défavorable dans l'essonne
amélie de montchalin numéro cinq du
gouvernement pourrait perdre sa place en
cas de défaite dimanche
pour l'âme pour les élections dimanche
avec un petit mot du maire de retour sur
le terrain la ministre bonjour monsieur
pour les élections je vous donne a du
mal à imprimer nous avons besoin du
conseil des ministres oui après c'est ça
la campagne après lassé des échanges qui
doit pas très longtemps le porte à porte
c'est pour ça que je fais beaucoup
permet d'aborder des changes avait plus
approfondie a pris les gens qui
s'arrêtent bonjour monsieur pour les
élections dimanche avec un petit mot du
maire madame avec un petit mot du maire
et même quand on la reconnaît ce n'est
pas forcément pour les jeter des fleurs
ministre vous avez bien bel et bien en
fait pour tout vous dire un petit mot du
maire derrière alors dites moi tout
quand est ce que vous allez augmenter le
point d'indicé des fonctionnaires
affiches géantes meeting avec bruno le
maire en coulisses la majorité tente par
tous les moyens de sauver le soldat
monchal un honnête le sujet c'est pas ma
personne c'est pas ça moi sujet c'est
qu'est ce qui pour notre pays émergent
de cette élection qui sont les députés
qui vont faire la loi ou qui vont faire
le débat dans les prochaines cinq années
donc on n'est pas en train de parler
voyez d'un sujet individuel le sujet
c'est qu'est ce qui se passe votre pays
face à elle jérôme guedj représentants
de l'alliance de la gauche est arrivée
en tête au premier tour n'a qu'un nom à
la bouche madame de montchalin elle
refuse tous les débats qu'on propose
avait pas la confrontation et préfère
m'insulter sur les plateaux que faire la
confrontation ça les intéresse c est
vecteur de renvoyer le ministre ou pas
j'ai l'impression moi je veux pas
personnaliser mais hi-fi savent qu'ils
font d'une pierre deux coups il ya il ya
quelqu'un qui incarne le bilan des
manuels macron très clairement elle a
été responsable de toutes les décisions
qui ont été prises sur l'hôpital public
sur le manque de profs dans les dans les
écoles et par conséquent bas il faut
qu'elle assume son bilan et
même si salle expose à la défaite pour
l'éviter est resté ministre amélie de
montchanin a jusqu'à dimanche pour
rattraper ses sept points de retard sur
son adversaire
brégeon
qu'est ce qui peut se passer si vous
avez quelques défaites parmi les 15
ministres on sait qu'un à plusieurs
amylie de montchalin lacets l'essonne
stanislas guérini à paris clément bonne
aussi madame bourguignon dans le pas de
calais pour commencer ils sont tous
qualifiés au second tour ils font tous
campagne jusqu'à la dernière minute et
moi j'appelle l'ensemble des électeurs
convient que la france garde cette
stabilité convient qu'on puisse avancer
sur notre programme à faire un choix
très clair dans chacune des
circonscriptions que vous citez est bien
au delà d'ailleurs et en permettant leur
élection dimanche prochain maintenant je
suis pas là pour faire de la de la
politique fiction quand il faudrait
quand même d'un pays aussi un vote
sanction n'est pas pour rien que ça
c'est jean l'elysée moi je j'ai beaucoup
de respect pour les ministres qui
justement sort de leur ministère ce hors
des plateaux télé et vont se confronter
à ce qu'il ya probablement de plus beau
dans le monde politique que ce qu'est le
suffrage universel aller sur les marchés
allaient faire du porte-à-porte aller
faire campagne c'est pas facile parce
que j'aurai de l'expression communément
admise en a apporté deux baffes alors
c'est mieux quand on en prend pas mais
enfin en tout état de cause sa demande
du courage et ya pas d circonscription
facile et d'autres difficiles faire
campagne sa demande toujours du courage
et moi j'ai vraiment je salue vraiment
ou toutes celles et ceux qui s'engagent
sur les législatives et tout c est ce qu
ils l'ont fait sur les campagnes prix
sages a more a man ray dans toutes les
circonscriptions où les ministres
quelques ministres que j'ai cités sont
en difficulté on est sur des plus tôt
des terres de gauche au centre gauche
qui ont été emportées largement en 2007
par les maquereaux nist notamment à
paris à paris c'est important de voir
qu'en fait les électeurs je sais pas si
c'est les bobos ou coin mais ils veulent
la gauche il ya eu une mutation du
lectorat macro nice depuis 2010 est un
convoi assez tôt en réalité en bois des
élections dès les élections européennes
vous avez un électorat de centre-droit
qui à ce moment là et bien vote emmanuel
macron d'où le très mauvais score à
l'époque de françois xavier bellamy et
de l'autre côté vous avez un électorat
du centre gauche qui pour partie en tout
cas à peu près
la moitié de l'électorat 2017 va est
bien rompre avec la macro ni avec pour
le coup une opposition qui devient
structurelle notamment dans les centres
villes ce qui pose un problème parce que
évidemment quand vous avez des députés
qui ont été élus sur une carte
électorale et que et bien cinq ans plus
tard où vous avez une nouvelle carte
électorale qui se construit et bien vous
avez aujourd'hui des fiefs et l'eire qui
sont tombés lors des fins qui
apparaissent comme devant tomber
dimanche prochain dans l'escarcelle de
renaissance et de l'autre côté bien vous
avez des fiefs de gauche qui reviennent
à la gauche est donc évidemment ça crée
des difficultés pour ouvrir une crise
politique où ce serait juste un mauvais
signal si vous avez deux trois quatre
ministres qui sont battus est ce que
c'est une hypothèse ça va ouvrir en tout
cas une crise j'irai du prozac est du
fonctionnement du gouvernement c'est à
dire qu'on a vue qui n'est pas forcément
d'arrière-ban aujourd'hui en macro ni
amélie de montchanin est tout de même un
post qu'un poste charnière dans ce
gouvernement et donc évidemment ça peut
créer un certain nombre de difficultés
mais surtout ça risque d'être pris comme
un désaveu pour emmanuel macron et ça
risque de créer des remous au sein de la
majorité aujourd'hui vous avez notamment
un pôle gauche de la majorité qui se
sont un tout petit peu mise à part parce
que en effet et bien cette campagne qui
s'ouvre elle n'est pas il n'est pas n
est pas fait pour le pour l armée
l'honneur en fait ces ministres ont
aussi pour beaucoup d'entre elles et
d'entre eux un bilan et un bilan qu'il
est difficile d'assumer la fermeture des
lits d'hôpitaux le vote d'amélie de
montchanin de montchalin par rapport aux
néonicotinoïdes décidément je me suis
donné une phrase difficile à dire tout
ça par rapport à des électeurs et des
électrices qui veulent du changement qui
veut la justice sociale et climatique ça
ne passe pas et face aux ministres on a
aussi d'excellents et d' excellente
candidate donc j'en profite pour saluer
nos égos chars face à elisabeth bornes
les emballages anne-marie qui face à
stéphane
beaucoup de comptes de campagne
attention mais attention qui lui
serait de rester sur au niveau national
parce que jamais on oui mais voilà trop
de comptes de campagne c'est important
pour une chose c'est par rapport à la
tenue du bilan du gouvernement et la
tenue aussi de certains ministres qui
sont investis et quand on voit qu'il ya
toujours dans les dispositifs de la
république en marche et du gouvernement
des hommes accusés de violences sexistes
et sexuelles qui sont toujours candidats
comme damien abad
raison de son jeu qu'il était accusé de
violences sexistes et sexuelles ce qui l
invite à lire les nouveaux témoignages
qui sont dans médiapart ce soir et à
voter massivement après jour vous
réponds juste à propos de damien abad
très rapidement la justice en france
c'est des poursuites des enquêtes ou des
cons diana jérôme peyrat dans le dixième
jeu terminent tout votre je termine
jeudi à londres il n'ya dans le cas de
damien abad ni enquête ni poursuites ni
condamnation juste pour rappeler très
factuellement les choses quand on fait
de la politique on se situe lorsqu'il
état de droit et dans ce que sont les
décisions justice et on n'y aurait ni
poursuite est en fait la nation ça ne
suffit pas
thibault qui vous aurez viendrait très
très grave ça engendrait un peu ce que
disait benjamin morel sur les
difficultés à venir parce que je pense
que si
ensemble des connaissances n'a pas et si
tu te fais possible 2 189 députés
c'est-à-dire la majorité absolue il ira
forcément une négociation qui va
s'ouvrir avec l air et ce sera très
compliqué parce que
sinon sa part aziz non mais simplement
ça va être très compliqué parce que
c'est un bloc disons sont ceux qui ne se
sont pas ralliés jusqu'à présent et ce
sera dur non ce sera pas ingouvernable
ce soit vrai il y en a toujours et toute
façon franchement on peut pas dire que
il ya eu énormément de réformes qui ont
été faites pendant cette période c'est
pas cette arrivée de
bien sûr et puis toute façon c'est la
démocratie c'est très bien mais je suis
pour la démocratie
plusieurs découvertes et maquereau est
il capable à tva la nature du compromis
pour killers m c'est un vrai sujet mais
il devait y être contraints quoi qu'il
arrive parce que même si une majorité
absolue va falloir négocier avec le
modem et avec horizons qui ont les clés
de la majorité est pour l'heure où
edouard philippe et françois bayrou ont
quelques raisons d'être mécontents à la
fois des investitures et des postes
qu'ils ont obtenus au gouvernement donc
de toute façon ça va être compliqué s'il
n'y a pas de majorité absolue en effet
il faut aller voir du côté peut-être de
l air ou ailleurs mais dans tous les cas
il va falloir entrer dans une dynamique
de coalition qu'à sa confiance et ça va
redonner
la fois jeu pour nuancer pour pour
nuancer cinq minutes sur le dirait le le
problème que ça peut poser il faut voir
que à part en france en grande bretagne
tous les gouvernements européens sont
des systèmes de coalition et c'est
justement c'est ce que veut dire je
pense que c'est plutôt une bonne chose
je pense que c'est ce que les français
qui sont des politiques parfois un peu
vicieux et parce qu'ils aiment bien la
politique sont peu machiavélique ça peut
c'est un peu l'assemblée comme vous
restez avec nous avait beaucoup parlé on
va s'arrêter là on n'a même pas pu
écouter michel rocard on avait une belle
archives de l'ina vous écoutez justement
regarde aller on ne touchera aucun mal
et pour vous faire plaisir vous aurez
moins de temps je vous préviens je vais
trop car si vous l'avez assez dommage on
me dit qu'on ne peut pas l'écouter bon
en tout cas vous avez
c'était le 49 3 et on l'entendait à
l'assemblée nationale utiliser le 49-3
notamment sur la rue othon
rappelé compliqué vont l'écouter ou
l'écoutent pas aller on écoute j'entends
donc que chacun prenne ses
responsabilités
à commencer par mois qui viennent
c'est pourquoi conformément au troisième
alinéa de l'article 49 de la
constitution
j'engage la responsabilité de mon
gouvernement
benjamin morel c'est qu'on peut plus
gouverner comme ça pour deux raisons
d'abord parce qu'à l'époque rocard peut
s'appuyer sur deux groupes qui acceptent
de s'abstenir en cas de motion de
censure les communistes et les
centristes et 1 49 3 c'est quoi c'est de
dire grosso modo c'est soit vous
acceptez le texte soit vous me renverser
et si vous renversez passe la motion de
censure ne passe pas vous avez accepté
le texte donc cette abstention était
nécessaire par ailleurs depuis 2008 on
limiter l'usagé du 49 alinéa 3 à un
texte par session hors projet de loi de
finances ont donc aujourd'hui on peut
plus comme michel rocard ou verna au
coût de 49 ans
pour l'autre en salle et bah voila
merci beaucoup c'était très vivant merci
pour pour vos éclairages et bonne
campagne vous allez rester avec moi
franz-olivier giesbert parce qu'on va
parler à présente en attendant de gaulle
aux éditions alpes michel c'est un titre
éloquent vous allez nous expliquer qui
en dit long sur ce que vous appelez les
incapables de 2022 oh non comme
d'habitude vous n'épargnez personne pas
même emmanuel macron qui lui aussi a
multiplié pourtant les clins d'oeil à de
gaulle avec de nombreuses références
alors de gaulle macron vraiment rien à
voir et ben marion becker vous sommet à
la question regarder
si on vous invite franz olivier giesbert
c'est parce qu'on s'interroge emmanuel
macron se prendrait-il pour le nouveau
de gaulle pas celui de l'appel du
18-juin non plutôt celui de 1958 celui
qui a mis fin à une quatrième république
instable politiquement et à bout de
souffle l'appel qui m'est adressée par
le pays
exprime son instinct du salut
s'il me charge de le conduire c'est
qu'il veut aller non certainement vers
la facilité
mais vers l'effort et le renouveau franz
olivier giesbert vous êtes sans doute
l'un des mieux placés pour répondre à
cette question
journaliste vous avez dirigé les
rédactions du nouvel observateur du
figaro vous êtes aujourd'hui
éditorialiste au point mais aussi
écrivain des romans des essais
politiques et historiques dont les
derniers consacré au général de gaulle
il y a un an dans le sursaut vous
analysiez déjà c'est ça la leçon du
gaullisme quand on veut on peut voyez
c'est le contraire des politiciens
d'aujourd'hui des politicards ou des
politichiens comme dirait jeudi c'est de
gaulle ça passe ou ça casse c'est la
fameuse blague de mark twain un type
arrivent ils savaient pas que c'est
impossible il le fait voilà c'est ça le
général de gaulle la nostalgie du
gaullisme depuis sa disparition tous les
politiques se réclament de son legs dans
votre dernier livre sur un ton insolent
voulait confronter à de gaulle
ils sont le théâtre des incapables on ne
voit pas bien quel est le lilliputien
qui pourrait à bon droit faire valoir
ses titre d'héritier pour vous le
général de gaulle c'est avant tout une
méthode une vision de la france et une
façon de gouverner
un homme qui n'a peur de rien et de cela
franz olivier giesbert vous estimé qu
aucun de ses successeurs ne peut s'en
réclamer emmanuel macron essaye avec le
dépassement des clivages son conseil de
la refondation clin d'oeil à l'ambitieux
conseil national de la résistance mais à
vous lire sans y parvenir alors on vous
pose la question franz olivier giesbert
de tous les hommes politiques
quel est le plus gaulliste aujourd'hui
réponse ah bah c'est facile
apparemment la question dure maintenant
sont des personnels x10 nom qui disent
non il y en a toujours c'est vrai les
gars c'est vrai comme à droite
où tiens les socialistes ils sont
opposés à l'accord de la ducasse et
décidant de la ba oui bien sûr de la
musique ou de la nuque ps je sais pas
comment il faut d' les résistants les
résistants
plein mais bien sûr il ira partout et
c'est pareil à droite c'est pareil au
centre je pense que c'est ça ce sont des
gens qui disent non et c'est ça c'est ça
le kühler c'est une phrase de gaulle ça
veut dire aller là où on peut dire aussi
donné un coup de pied dans la
fourmilière c'est à dire que pour faire
bouger les choses il faut avancer et
puis cette fois ce que de gaulle répété
tout le temps mais qui est très amusante
vous l'entendez encore c'est pas lui qui
l'a inventé les chiens aboient la
caravane passe allez on avance mais on
écoute aussi on est toujours un peu oui
si quelqu'un vous dit quelque chose qui
contredisent que vous pensiez vous êtes
toujours prêt à en discuter avec lui et
macron alors aucune passerelle possible
le dépassement des clivages les
références historiques
la fondation il ya pas la culture
historique c'est important pour ma cran
je pense qu'il devrait faire un stage
reprendre un peu l'histoire
oui exactement je crois que c'est
important il commence à la voir il a eu
avec l'ukraine il comprend un peu ce qui
se passe mais l'histoire est tragique
c'est ce que nous apprend l'histoire et
elle bégaye tout le temps et même si
parfois on a le sentiment que tout va
s'arranger ben non ça s'arrange pas ça
s'arrange mal et si vous voulez c'est ça
un petit peu le défaut de la cuirasse et
puis c'est vrai que sur le plan
historique il a fait quand même quelques
il ya quelques mais content quand on
regarde le dernier qu'un canal je sais
pas les commandes et les crimes de
l'humanité contre l'humanité a dit que
la france vraiment la décolonisation
vous parlez de la connaissez la période
de
jeu quand je dis ça je me prononce pas
du tout mon savoir et canalisations j'ai
des connaissances comme tout le monde
sur la période qu'on traverse
aujourd'hui il fait cette référence au
cnr et il assumait il dit au fond on est
dans un contexte comparable il dit au
fond le défi climatique le retour de la
guerre en europe la récession qui guette
tout ça nous ramène en 1945 où il
fallait tout reconstruire je suis
sensible à ça bien entendu sauf que
c'est de la com on va voir un usage sous
ça devrait passer par pas comme ça par
un communiqué ça doit être quelque chose
de oui parce que c'est vrai que les
temps sont graves regardez ce qui se
passe c'est vrai en ukraine à un pays
qui est attaqué par par un voisin qui a
d'ailleurs des visées puisque quand on
entend ce qu'ils disent sur la peau
l'homme peut-être sur les pays baltes
enfin bon on est rentré dans une sorte
de délire qui rappelle quand même des
temps qui n'était pas terrible donc vous
avez ça vous avez une crise économique à
venir aussi parce que tout le monde le
sait on a on n'a pas très bien géré
quand même notamment en france
l'allemagne a bien géré mais on a quand
même pire on le paye ce avec un déficit
du commerce extérieur on dépense
beaucoup plus on dépense quand même
beaucoup plus qu'on produit et ce à un
moment donné il faut payer voyez ce que
je veux dire que vous avez des candidats
comme mélenchon pour pas le site et
propose 265 millions les 150 mêlée à 160
milliards 76 les dépenses
supplémentaires et voilà qui dit pardon
qui 250 milliards de dollars
commentaires et qui doit trouver alors
là c'est la poudre de perlimpinpin dos
santos fmi l'initiateur qu'elle est tien
choisir étiez alors on va pas faire ce
débat mais ça m'a fait aujourd'hui mais
vous dites quand même dans votre livre
koba vous avez toujours eu un petit
faible pour lui malgré tout échoue
commune que vous avez même l'un des
jeunes et il ya des années si vous avez
fini le rêve de lys la gauche mais c'est
quelqu'un que je connais depuis très
longtemps
mon âge j'ai vu le sien drôle même
pratiquement et c'est vrai que il a du
charme d'abord c'est un grand orateur il
a une certaine culture simplement
quelque chose qui va pas là il est à la
pêche aux électeurs il s'en fout
d'ailleurs son programme attendait 6
penser une seule seconde parce qu'ils
étaient quand même lucides qui serait
élu il aurait pas ce qu'on
souffre mais non c'est pas la gauche
des blues de l'année c'est à dire tous
les journalistes aplati devant mélenchon
dans les médias vous avez le temps de
parole de la nuque quand même complète
nous explique c'est une grande victoire
pour l'onu je constate parce que moi je
suis très content très basique je
compare avec ce qui se passait avant de
regarder la gauche en 2012 s'était 37%
aujourd'hui la gauche c'est 10 points de
moins c'est 27% 25,7 c'est à dire c'est
pas grand chose et c'est une gauche qui
te l'a menée par l'extrême gauche la
france est soumise ce n'est pas la même
gauche n'est plus une gauche gouvernants
est passé de 2 37 à 27 ans finalement en
disant il ya un énorme problème on
explique que c'est une victoire dans un
td de tous m'ont tous quand ce ghana
chapitre dans votre livre vous posez la
question l'islamo gauchisme
va-t-il tuer la gauche jean michel
blanquer a été sèchement battue il avait
fait se satisfait mogo chine le coeur de
son combat où c'était pas le coeur le
coeur c'était quand même le coeur
c'était quand même
nom puis tous ont trépassé excusez-moi
son travail c'était et d'ailleurs on
aura certainement les effets dans
quelques années c'était de remettre tout
l'effort sur le pré nerfs que
l'éducation nationale avait oublié et
disons au cours des dernières dessinée
je pense qu'il a eue de ce point de vue
qu'il incarnait politiquement qui a été
battu à votre avis je pense pas je pense
pas je pense qu'il a il arrivait dans un
cycle parachutage pas forcément très
bien préparé mais je pense que c'est
très dommage je pense que et je pense
qu'il a il ya un flou d'abjection qui
lui est tombée dessus moi qui
m'interroge je dire il ya beaucoup de m
et ça je suis désolé ça vient des
extrêmes ce traitement gauche ça vient
de l'extérieur mais ça bien sûr tous
ceux qui sont le plus dans l'aisne
aujourd'hui c'est l'extrême gauche alors
il d'ailleurs mélenchon qui est un très
bon politique est un électoral ysk est
un démagogue il y joue sur sa joue
là-dessus attendu ici les utiliser avant
d'accueillir nos affranchis clients qui
vont vous interpeller avec leur parti
pris un petit mot sur eric zemmour
j'étais étonné vous lui dit vous vous
accordez beaucoup quand même de qualité
vous dites que c'est un grand orateur
qu'il a du charisme et voulu voyez même
un avenir pour 2027 pour vous c'est plus
qu'un polémiste c'est d'oeuvrer un homme
politique c'est à dire que c'est la
politique c'est un métier moi j'ai
jamais cru à zemmour pour 2022 ça
pouvait vérifier je me plais départ
idiot disons qu'ils feraient jamais 5%
bas il a quand même fait sept îles a
fait plus que j'avais prévu et je pense
que c'est un métier s'ils restent s'il
apprend le métier live mail après une
belle baffe six représentent
effectivement il peut arriver mais à pas
grand-chose toute façon marine le pen de
laquelle marine le pen il ya problème
c'est qu'elle sait pas à rassembler
c'est la politique c'est quand même
aussi rassembler et d'ailleurs je pense
qu'elle aurait fait l'alliance avec ces
mots à le tuer j'ai mitterrand pour tous
les communistes il a fait alliance avec
eux
c'était de la bêtise pure c'est à dire
où je sais pas où la consistance ou non
mais c'est très étrange
on lui file du déjeuner on fait venir
tous les photographes qui arrive au lui
met la main par dessus mais le mec il
est mort après et c est même pas capable
de faire ça c'est très étrange parce que
si vous faites le le le l'addition le
pen plus et moore ça fait quand même
plus de 23% c'est vrai c'est
presqu'autant que la nuque mais ce dont
on parle mais elle a parfois des blesse
les belles furent en politique dont on
pas se remettre c'est peut-être son son
cas avec eric zemmour franz-olivier
giesbert vous restez avec mon attendant
de gaulle c'est chez albin michel en
attendant d'ailleurs le prochain
président aux éditions gallimard
sortir en octobre vous accueillez avec
moi les les affranchis pour leur parti
pris ce soir on va retrouver le carnet
de campagne des amendes à gamma jean
rémi baudot va nous parler de emmanuel
macron encore lui enfant gâté de la
politique pour la première fois au pied
de mur nous direz et puis fanny
guinochet pour l'économie le
gouvernement va-t-il renoncer à baisser
les impôts des entreprises face aux
déficits qui se creusent c'est votre
question vous y tenez france a franchi
les voici bonsoir bonsoir et merci
d'être avec nous elle demande un gars va
on commence avec vous on vous retrouve
pendant cet entre-deux-tours évidemment
jusque jusqu'à dimanche et puis sur le
terrain dimanche prochain et vous allez
nous parler de cinq nouveaux élus ce
soir absolument il ya puis 577 députés à
élire mais 572 y en a cinq qui ont été
élus dès le premier tour un député
sortant de la majorité yannick favennec
bécaud et quatre députés de la nuque et
eux ils sont arrivés désignait regrouper
regarder sur ces images de marion
bouziès et de virgile tron alors parmi
eux il y a deux sortants alexis corbière
en seine-saint-denis danièle obono à
paris et deux nouveaux visages sofiane
chikhi roues et sarah le grain est lui
également à paris ils étaient
accompagnés par la présidente du groupe
matis le panneau qui à les qualifier
pour le second tour alors ils ont fait
le v de la victoire et de la nuque ils
ont levé le poing comme il l'avait fait
il ya cinq ans et puis vous allez nous
parler je cherche ma relance du parcours
d'accueil alors des députés en fait c
est ce que tous les nouveaux députés
vont faire ils ont suivi respect me
parcourt avec la remise de la fameuse
mallette myriam on la connaît bien ici à
l'assemblée c'est sofia chekir ou qui a
accepté de nous faire la démonstration
voici ce qu'il ya dedans les chats on
met le rouge côté coup quand on est
député il ya la cocarde pour mettre sur
la voiture l'insigne qu'on appelle le
baromètre ici à l'assemblée puis le
règlement de l'assemblée nationale
la nulle part promis de s'en servir
assez souvent rhénan cette législature
elle exactement qui a fait ses preuves
en la matière exactement ensuite
direction aller diot photo pour prendre
et bien la photo officielle
évidemment c'est celle qu'on va
retrouver et bien sûr le site internet
de l'assemblée et aussi sur le badge des
députés tous les huissiers vont bien
étudié toutes les photos comme il y aura
peut-être des petits nouveaux ils seront
comme ça qui est député pour finir il ya
la visite des lieux les zones clés de
l'assemblée la salle des quatre colonnes
tous les journalistes la connaissent
bien tu veux on a vu fait alors ça il
s'était en tout cas hors frais ça les
gêne d'ailleurs ce n'est pas les emplois
labeaume entend bien lui on y va
peut-être un peu moins mais on en
reparlera et
puis évidemment pas le moment at elle
convaincu l'air le clou du spectacle
c'est l'entrée la visite de l'hémicycle
évidemment un peu impressionnant et
impressionner les députés écouter sarah
le grain
bien sûr c'est la maison du peuple alors
je connaissais 1 j'ai déjà eu l'occasion
de visiter notamment avec des amis
députés ça se fait mais à venir là comme
un représentant du peuple bien sûr c'est
quelque chose de très émouvant et je
n'en ai puig myriam sachez que quand on
leur demande où est ce qu'ils vont
siéger dans cet hémicycle bas il
répondra sur le banc des ministres oui
évidemment on a vu ça tout à l'heure
voilà l'espoir fait vivre on verra ça on
verra ça dimanche prochain alors pour
finir on va sortir grâce à nos confrères
qu'on va citer ce soir d'une immense
interrogations sémantique absolument
null null null baisse a été la question
pendant toute la campagne crois que vous
êtes plutôt team us vous ai entendu
meyers a généré une épaisse alors que
franchement c'est pas cher il peut alors
visiblement c'était pas clair pour
personne écoutez ce petit montage la
base sur la nuque nubes la nuque la
nuque du ps alors là nul car il est même
la nuque c'est bien nous notre collègue
jason wiels il n'y est pas allé par
quatre chemins il a demandé à l'académie
française ce qu'ils valaient dire le
service du dictionnaire lui a répondu
alors comme il n'y a pas de points qui
séparent le n lui le pe et le s c'est
pas un sigle c'est un acronyme j'espère
que j'y pas de bêtises la voilà c'est
l'arrêt prononcé nuque la nuque comme la
jeunesse espagne voilà même si
l'académie reconnaître delajoux fossé
reste mal fixé oui eh ben on va demander
à laquelle
vous connaissez mal nommer les choses
c'est ajouter
il prononce tous en entier maintenant
ils disent la nouvelle union populaire
écologique et sociale comme ça on
tranche pas sur la bonne nation jean
réunion on enchaîne avec vous vous
observez l'actuelle majorité
présidentielle depuis le premier tour
est selon vous la macro ni un rapport
contrariée avec l'exercice démocratique
oui cela s'illustre notamment par une
phrase prononcée aujourd'hui par
emmanuel macron le chef de l'état en
mode président américain sur le tarmac
d'orly qui donne son interprétation du
vote de dimanche
lors du premier tour vous avez placé en
tête la majorité présidentielle et je
vous en remercie chaleureusement
et vous avez été plus nombreux encore à
faire part de vos doutes vos angoisses
vos peurs soit en vous abstenant soit en
choisissant d'autres candidats voilà
donc je résume ce quoi vous avez voté
pour lui soit vous avez exprimé des
peurs et des angoisses emmanuel macron
qui rejoue une énième fois son - ou le
chaos on est à l'épisode 370 disons le
et emmanuel macron je dis pas qu'il
n'est pas démocrate mais il ya une
vision assez personnel de la répartition
et de l'exercice du pouvoir et son camp
semble assez mal vivre les aléas de des
déconvenues électorales important ça
n'est pas sa première élection non mais
quand on regarde il n'en a pas fait
beaucoup des élections et puis surtout
n'a pas eu beaucoup d'échecs 2017
présidentielle législative 2019 il est
au coude à coude pour les européennes
plus tard il faut attendre les
municipales et les régionales pour une
raclée la macro n'y parvient néanmoins
imposé le récit que ça n'est pas un
revers dans les urnes et cette semaine
on voit bien ce récit il n'est pas
possible face à un mélenchon stratège à
une gauche unie il ya la fébrilité savez
en lumière la difficulté des manières
macro et de ses proches probablement
d'accepter de ne pas écraser
l'adversaire ou peut-être de ne pas bien
avoir du mal avec ce résultat disperse
comprendra hiller plus des vieux
discours de giscard de mitterrand de
tout le monde pourquoi est ce que
j'aurais été président
difficile d'abandonner des parts de
marché d'ailleurs ça m'inspire un
parallèle le maquereau nice n'a été
pensé comme une machine à gagner puis
s'est mué en entreprise de management
politique objectif délivrer des
résultats comme on dit dans les startups
sauf que le marché politique du
maquereau nice n'est pas suffisamment
stable que les filiales locales ne sont
pas assez puissantes les partenaires
sociaux partenaires commerciaux un peu
capricieux en face il y à des
concurrents qui ont qui ont créé une
holding tout ça ça a fragilisé le
business model macron confronter à la
réalité d'un mouvement de balancier
politique loupé à de la macro n'y ait
pour l'instant déstabilise marque macron
pourquoi ce parallèle avec le monde de
l'entreprise parce que j'ai problème en
était trop longtemps j'en dise police
janvier c'était économique parce
qu'aussi le marketing politique a ses
limites parce que à force d'en même
temps on perd un peu de vue quel est le
produit de la macro nice le produit
vendu son adn politique il est en train
de guérir à la nôtre
dans les entreprises le rapport de force
vis-à-vis de la concurrence le parti à
l'om n'est pas particulièrement
parce que mélenchon ne fait pas cinq ans
le maquereau nice m'a pas dit qu'il y
avait des comptes des concurrents à
traiter parfois à respecter des partis
d'opposition des corps intermédiaires
des partenaires sociaux cette fébrilité
dans l'entre-deux-tours allemande
peut-être un manque de culture politique
en tout cas la politique ça ça prend
parfois au travers des échecs et
dimanche sera évidemment un test pour la
macro ni merci ça s'appelle un parti
pris merci à vous on va continuer les
entreprises parce que vous qui êtes si
soucieux de nos déficits publics il se
pourrait bien que avec le contexte
économique et même peut-être la victoire
la victoire de possibles 1 2 de la nu
par camion midi avec un score à bord non
100% et on les lance
son programme j'ai pas dit qu'elles
aient gagné gp2 il aimerait son
programme asia la dynamique du rn
également de la femme et on l'a dit 3 1
pour emmanuel macron de faire passer des
mesures de soutien aux entreprises comme
il souhaite le faire notamment sur les
impôts de production vous savez qu'il a
prévu de baisser de 7 milliards d'euros
les impôts de production il l'a dit au
medef à tous les partenaires patronaux
20 représentants patronaux qui recevait
aujourd'hui sauf que dans un contexte
pareil un contexte économique très dur
alors qu'il a déjà baissé ses impôts de
production et pourrait revoir sa copie
alors qu'il espérait aller un cran plus
loin alors pourquoi parce que la gauche
est vent debout en général sur les aides
aux entreprises parce que quand on fait
des cadeaux pour les entreprises eh bien
il faut en faire aux salariés ou quand
on fait des aides le débat vous souvenez
c'est un vieux débat qui date de
françois hollande et dz de votre patron
politique de l'offre il y avait
nécessité de d'encadrer de conditionner
deux contreparties or là on le voit par
exemple les salaires augmentent mais
très légèrement face à une inflation qui
est très très forte alors en même temps
il va faire des cadeaux fiscaux aussi
avec la question de pouvoir d'achat il
ya des arbitrages qui sont fondamentaux
en ce moment donc où tout est mis pour
faire les cadeaux cherchent de l'argent
et divergents en voilà et les 7
milliards d'euros woody et les 7
milliards d'euros oui mais vous savez
que les taux remontent les 7 milliards
d'euros à deux baisses d'impôts de
production ça peut être utile pour payer
l'addition et puis en plus faire
aujourd'hui une politique de soutien aux
entreprises qui ont été très aidé
pendant le coc vide avec le quoi qu'il
en coûte c'est un risque politique
extrêmement fort il ya aussi le risque à
l'assemblée nationale on va voir ce que
ça va donner c'est la nouvelle
composition ça risque de batailler ferme
et puis un risque social aussi dans la
rue
quels arbitrages la compétitivité on
baisse les impôts des entreprises c'est
toujours mon choisy les prophètes
faut choisir la france mais vous pas
oublier les français parce que si c'est
très important la france c'est à dire on
voit bien en parler de de gaulle tout à
l'heure doug holyday obsédé par la
france et c'est pour bilou qui s'occupe
des français c'était doivent marcher sur
deux pieds d'ailleurs un pays pour qui
marche bien il doit fonctionner sur la
droite sur la gauche on verra en tout
cas ce terme arbitrage fondamentale il
sera rendu qu'en bas salaires de toute
façon dans le la première législature
dont la dans le paquet et or d'achat des
dans le pays cet été après les élections
merci beaucoup les affranchis aussi et
surtout merci pour la concision merci à
vous prendre si myriam auront ainsi une
très bonne émission
de gaulle merci albin michel le théâtre
des incapables c'est signé fog bonne
soirée documentaire à demain
[Musique]